Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同举办的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战赛。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Without a merry entrance episode. I hope you find it useful and I hope that you were able to use it and the approaches
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。希望你觉得它有用，并能运用其中的方法，
within it to reflect perhaps in your own practice or perhaps going through your day-to-day life in a mindful way, perhaps in supervision, perhaps as a reflective journal exercise. But I try to showcase the way that I live my life and how I use my own knowledge, not only for the clients I work with, but also for myself. And that is the topic of today's episode is when you can use your own knowledge to apply to yourself or to help work out what might be going on with you. So yeah, here it goes. I thought we would do this by looking at my life and my behaviour through a few key areas, key times where I wasn't feeling tip-top. Okay, so let's think about the first one that comes to mind, and it is in 2013 and at that point I have got a six weeks old baby, my first child and I had had no sleep for precisely six weeks and about two days, I had only just been able to start driving again
无论是用于你自己的实践，还是在日常生活中保持正念，亦或是在督导中，或者作为反思日记的练习。我试图展示我生活的方式，以及我如何运用自己的知识，不仅是为了我服务的客户，也是为了我自己。这正是今天节目的主题：当你能运用自己的知识来帮助自己，或理清自己身上可能发生的事情时。所以，是的，开始了。我想通过审视我生活中几个关键领域和关键时刻来完成这一点，那些我感觉不太好的时候。好的，让我们想想第一个想到的时刻，那是2013年，当时我有一个六周大的宝宝，我的第一个孩子，我已经整整六周零两天没睡过觉了，我才刚刚能开始开车，
because I'd had an emergency section and you can't start driving again until you've been signed off as safe to do so. That's usually around your six-week check. So I was like home with my baby who I was just on cloud nine with so despite the fact that he was an utter utter sleep thief at worst he woke like 31 times a night he was an absolute terror when it came to night time he also didn't really like nap time very much either um but at all other times he was joyful he was so smiley and gorgeous and I just adored being his mummy I still do it's just oh I just felt like it was just me and him so I'm married I'm still married at the time but it's just like it was just this just unique adoration just like amazing it's just like we'd both landed on like planet perfection apart from and aside from the fact that he did not sleep and I was like
因为我做了紧急剖腹产，在被确认安全之前是不能开车的。这通常是在六周检查之后。所以我当时和我的宝宝待在家里，我对他简直是爱不释手，尽管他是个彻头彻尾的“睡眠小偷”，最糟糕的时候一晚上会醒31次，他在夜间简直是个小恶魔，而且他也不太喜欢小睡，嗯，但在其他所有时间里，他都很开心，总是笑眯眯的，非常可爱，我非常喜欢做他的妈妈。我现在依然如此，只是，哦，我感觉就像只有我和他在一起。当时我结婚了，现在也还结婚，但这是一种独特的爱，就像奇迹一样，就像我们都降落在了完美星球上，除了他睡觉的问题，我当时想，
who is this child because I love sleep prior to becoming a mummy it was not unheard of me to have a lie-in on days when I wasn't working and then wake up and then have some breakfast and then have a nap and then sometimes I don't even have an afternoon nap and then I go to sleep and sleep all night long. I loved sleep so to then have this child who really was not finding sleep that natural which I know is really common, I just was not prepared for how exhausting that would be. You know, I don't know if you've ever been that tired, but when I reflect on that time, I think about it, not necessarily so much in the six weeks, first six weeks, although it was difficult to begin with, but it went on until he was 20 months his
这孩子是谁？因为在成为妈妈之前我非常喜欢睡觉，在不工作的日子里睡个懒觉，醒来吃早餐，然后再睡个午觉，有时甚至不需要午睡，然后我就能睡一整晚，这对我来说并不罕见。我热爱睡眠，所以面对这个觉得睡觉并不自然的孩子（我知道这很常见），我真的没有准备好这会有多累人。你知道，我不知道你是否曾经那么累过，但当我反思那段时间时，我并不一定是指前六周，虽然刚开始确实很困难，但这种情况一直持续到他20个月大，
sleep chaos um but at times you know if it'd been particularly wild at night there'd been many many wakings perhaps after only 40 day I felt like head fog and I was more likely to eat rubbish because of the unique way that our ghrelin, ghrelin, ghrelin how do you say I have no idea but it's a it's a hormone which is really indicated in our eating and our eating hormones suppressant when we've had enough to eat. But there's also leptin as well, which I believe is quite indicated in appetite. And both of those hormones are affected when we are very tired. So we might find that there's some evidence even that people at buffets, if they've been sleep deprived, will consume more calories than people who've had, you know, seven and a half to eight hours plus sleep per night. So, yeah, this stuff matters. So the time I'm telling you about is when he was just over six weeks old.
他的睡眠混乱，嗯，但有时，如果晚上特别折腾，醒了很多次，可能只睡了40分钟，我就觉得头脑发昏，而且因为我们的饥饿素（ghrelin，ghrelin，ghrelin，怎么读我不知道，但它是一种与进食密切相关的激素，当我们吃饱时，它会抑制我们的进食激素）的独特作用，我更容易吃垃圾食品。还有瘦素（leptin），我相信它也与食欲密切相关。当我们非常疲惫时，这两种激素都会受到影响。甚至有证据表明，如果睡眠不足，人们在自助餐时摄入的卡路里会比每晚睡七个半到八小时以上的人更多。所以，是的，这些都很重要。我告诉你的那个时间点是他刚满六周大的时候。
I'd been able to get out and about in my car so I'd been to a breastfeeding support group and was just trying to work out why why it was all still kind of quite painful and very quickly he was assessed by a lactation consultant she was like he's got a posterior tongue tie um and yeah there's some people that don't think that's a thing but I could promise you from the state of my body at that time um it's a thing I absolutely am on board with that being a thing and it should not have been hurting me as much as it was um and on that same um of days, it might maybe even have been the same day, he was assessed by the GP for his kind of six week check. And they kind of said,
我当时已经能开车出门了，所以我去了一个母乳喂养支持小组，试图弄清楚为什么一切仍然那么痛苦。很快，他被一位哺乳顾问评估，她说他有后舌系带过短，嗯，是的，有些人认为这不存在，但我可以向你保证，从我当时身体的状态来看，嗯，它是存在的，我绝对认同它的存在，它不应该让我感到那么痛苦。而在那几天，甚至可能是同一天，他被全科医生（GP）进行了六周检查。他们说，
oh, I think he might have a bit of a squint in his eyes he's not focusing quite right we'd have expected it ordinarily to have corrected by now and so babies are often born that way but usually by about that age it's it's sort of corrected itself and I remember bathing him that night in the bath and just crying really I was thinking oh this like perfect baby now potentially needs some kind of minor surgery to his tongue I might need to have all sorts of appointments to help correct this squint and I just thought oh this is really sad I'm really sad I'm really really sad um and then I was and of course I was really tired I was meeting a friend um who is a fellow clin psych and he's now a mother um but wasn't at the time I was meeting her for lunch
哦，我觉得他的眼睛可能有点斜视，他聚焦得不太对，我们通常预期到这个年龄应该已经矫正了，婴儿出生时经常这样，但通常到这个年龄它会自行矫正。我记得那天晚上给他洗澡时，我真的哭了，我在想，哦，这个完美的宝宝现在可能需要某种小手术来处理舌头，我可能需要进行各种预约来帮助矫正这个斜视，我只是觉得，哦，这真的很令人难过，我真的很伤心，我真的非常非常伤心。嗯，然后，当然我真的很累。我当时正要去见一位朋友，她也是一位临床心理学家，现在也是一位母亲，但当时还不是。我正要去见她吃午饭，
in town um I think probably the following day or soon after that and we just sat there and I just had a good old cry and she was worried about me and my mental health at that time I think she thought I was perhaps you know developing postnatal depression or I wasn't coping very well so she wasn't worried that I was concerned to my baby she was just worried about me as a friend and worried about me because of her knowledge of psychology too. But I was able to use my theory and my reflections to know I wasn't experiencing depression at that stage. So I think an outsider and a GP, if I've been honest with them at that point, they might well have just indicated, you know, suggested that that's postnatal depression, you know, but actually I knew for me that it wasn't because I was still finding joy in him
在城里，我想大概是第二天或者之后不久。我们坐在那里，我大哭了一场。她当时很担心我和我的心理健康，我想她可能认为我患上了产后抑郁症，或者我应对得不太好。所以她并不是担心我会伤害我的宝宝，她只是作为朋友担心我，也因为她具备心理学知识而担心我。但我能够运用我的理论和反思来确认我当时并没有经历抑郁症。所以我认为，如果我当时对局外人或全科医生坦诚相待，他们很可能会指出，你知道，建议那是产后抑郁症，你知道，但实际上我知道对我来说并不是，因为我仍然能从他身上找到快乐，
and in activities. I was still eating, I was still sleeping when I could. I was just reacting to what felt like two quite big hiccups with my baby, you know, with his health. And I just, it just took a little bit of time to adjust for that. And by eight weeks, his tongue procedure had been done and things had settled down a bit. And I was hoping that that might improve his sleep. And of course it didn't. But then he was feeding better. And so my body was more comfortable. And so I just really felt like I really moved into just my flow of being a mummy, even though I was a tired mummy at that stage. And so things got better at that point and more effortless. And there was still so much joy and adoration around, despite the fact that he was an absolute sleep monkey. Now, thankfully, his squint did sort itself out.
在活动中也是。我还在吃东西，还在尽可能地睡觉。我只是在对宝宝健康方面出现的两个相当大的波折做出反应。我只是，这确实花了一些时间来适应。到了八周时，他的舌头手术已经完成，情况也稳定了一些。我曾希望这能改善他的睡眠，当然并没有。但他吃得更好了，所以我的身体更舒服了。所以我真的觉得我进入了做妈妈的状态，尽管当时我是一个疲惫的妈妈。所以在那一点上情况好转了，也更轻松了。尽管他是个彻头彻尾的“睡眠小猴子”，但周围依然充满了快乐和爱。现在，谢天谢地，他的斜视确实自行解决了。
So he never needed any treatment for that. It did resolve, which I was really pleased about. But I think I could easily have been pathologized at that stage as being depressed. But I was able to use that to know that I was just reacting to life events. And that is not to disparage anyone who is experiencing postnatal depression at all. This is just my observation of knowing my own self really well and knowing, you know, the markers for depression and feeling that they didn't apply to me it didn't you know it wasn't depression I was experiencing because we must allow and tolerate that our lives will have ebbs and flows that sometimes we will feel better sometimes we will feel worse and it's the good times that highlight the bad
所以他从未需要任何治疗。它确实解决了，我对此感到非常高兴。但我认为我当时很容易被病理化为抑郁症。但我能够利用这一点来了解我只是在对生活事件做出反应。这绝不是在贬低任何正在经历产后抑郁症的人。这只是我对自己非常了解，并且知道抑郁症的标志，并感觉到它们不适用于我的观察。它不是，你知道，我经历的不是抑郁症，因为我们必须允许并容忍我们的生活会有起伏，有时我们会感觉更好，有时我们会感觉更糟，正是美好的时光突显了糟糕的
times but it's also going through the bad times which really highlight the great times, isn't it? If you can reflect on some of the happiest times in your life, perhaps it's when you've been in the first flushes of new relationship or you've just moved house or you've got a new job and you just are so delighted. You know, you reflect on how find things and how much joy you're able to find in yourself and in your activities and in the things you do with people and sometimes you just can't keep that smile off your face and that's a really really lovely life stage and you must breathe into that you must lean into it you recognize it. It's okay to mindfully celebrate and reflect upon and kind of draw down upon those really good felt times to be able to draw on and
时光，但经历糟糕的时光也确实突显了美好的时光，不是吗？如果你能反思你生命中最快乐的一些时光，也许是你处于新恋情的最初阶段，或者你刚搬了新家，或者你得到了一份新工作，你感到非常高兴。你知道，你反思事情是多么顺利，你在自己身上、在你的活动中以及在你与人所做的事情中能找到多少快乐，有时你就是无法掩饰脸上的笑容，那是一个非常非常可爱的生命阶段，你必须沉浸其中，你必须依靠它，你必须认可它。以正念的方式去庆祝、反思并汲取那些真正美好的感受，以便在感觉不太好的时候能够利用和
reflect upon and to help you through times that feel less good. You know, you just know that better times are coming whatever you're experiencing right now. There's always hope. I firmly believe that. So let's break here for a short little snippet where we talk about the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. And I will be back along very, very shortly to talk with you about some more observations and reflections about my own mental health and my well-being journey psychologist then let this be your guide filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified so come and take a look it's right here in this book it's the clinical psychologist collective it's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. The Clinical Psychologist Collective book was a very helpful read and useful to step outside of the prep work for the
反思，并帮助你度过难关，这是没问题的。你知道，无论你现在经历什么，你都要知道美好的时光终会到来。总是有希望的。我坚信这一点。所以让我们在这里休息一下，谈谈《Aspiring Psychologist Collective》这本书。我很快就会回来，和你谈谈关于我自己的心理健康和幸福之旅的更多观察和反思。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南，书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验教训，所以来看看吧，就在这本书里，它是《Clinical Psychologist Collective》，它是《Clinical Psychologist Collective》。《Clinical Psychologist Collective》这本书是一本非常有帮助的读物，对于跳出准备
Declan Sci application process to really consider if this is something you want to do and reflect on your personal journey. It is a very nice read and kept me company on train journeys. I do think Marianne's guidance through her podcast, compassionate Q&A sessions and this book has played a part in my successful application this year. Thank you. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective.
Declan Sci申请过程的框架，真正思考这是否是你想要做的事情，并反思你的个人旅程非常有用。这是一本非常好的书，在火车旅行中陪伴着我。我确实认为Marianne通过她的播客、富有同情心的问答环节以及这本书，在我今年的成功申请中发挥了作用。谢谢。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验教训。所以来看看吧。它就在这本书里。它是《Clinical Psychologist Collective》。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Welcome back along. Thank you for staying tuned in and I hope you found that useful. So let's think about what I'm not saying during this episode. So I'm absolutely not saying that it's not possible to develop mental health difficulties. I'm absolutely not saying that there's anything wrong with you or other people if they do what I am talking about is using our extensive skills and training to try and do a bit of an audit of ourselves really and to look at using those skills in really being really super self-aware and reflective to kind of act as early help for yourself and for me I think about it as almost like daily gardening really for my
它是《Clinical Psychologist Collective》。欢迎回来。感谢你的收听，希望你觉得这很有用。那么，让我们思考一下我在本期节目中没有说的话。我绝对不是说患上心理健康问题是不可能的。我绝对不是说如果你或其他人有心理健康问题，你们有什么问题。我所谈论的是利用我们广泛的技能和培训，尝试对自己进行一次审计，并利用这些技能，真正做到超级自我意识和反思，从而为自己充当早期的帮助。对我来说，我把它看作是几乎像每天为我的
mental health you know just having a little bit of an overview of where I'm at. And I think that it can be, you know, really helpful to have this sort of approach in this sort of reflective style and space. And for me, I think it really helps make sure that what I'm experiencing as a state and when I say state I don't mean like oh you know they were in a right state although that's probably where it originates from a state is just you know something we're doing right now um but stops it from tipping over or developing into a trait. So for me, depression is when, you know, certain behaviours and, you know, symptoms and patterns of thinking and interacting start to become more entrenched. And so they're becoming, or they have become,
心理健康进行园艺一样，你知道，只是对我的现状有一个大致的了解。我认为，拥有这种方法和这种反思风格与空间是非常有帮助的。对我来说，我认为这确实有助于确保我所经历的是一种“状态”（当我说是状态时，我不是指“哦，你知道他们处于一种糟糕的状态”，尽管这可能就是它的起源，状态只是你现在正在做的事情），但它能阻止它演变成一种“特质”。所以对我来说，抑郁症是当某些行为、症状以及思维和互动模式开始变得更加根深蒂固时。所以它们正在，或者已经变成了，
or it seems like they are traits, like it won't change, that it's static. And for me, it's getting in ahead of that with myself, you know, to really do what I can do to stay on top of that and to practice what I preach I guess and I guess it might be useful for you to use some of these approaches with yourself and to be as open as I am being and to practice if it feels safe being as open as I am being in your supervision sessions, if that feels safe to do so. That said, if you do want to register for my supervision guide, which can help you shape your supervision relationships, then head out to the details in the show notes or head to my website and then it's just forward slash supervision. So, yeah, let's crash on with the rest of the
或者看起来它们是特质，好像它不会改变，它是静态的。对我来说，这是在它发生之前就先发制人，你知道，真正做我能做的一切来保持掌控，并实践我所宣扬的。我想，如果你能在自己的督导会议中运用其中一些方法，并像我一样开放，如果感觉安全的话，像我一样开放地进行实践，这可能对你很有用。话虽如此，如果你想注册我的督导指南，它可以帮助你塑造你的督导关系，那么请查看节目说明中的详细信息，或前往我的网站，然后输入斜杠supervision。所以，是的，让我们继续剩下的
episode. But just wanted to add that caveat so that you knew that I wasn't being all hatist at all. Absolutely not stacks of compassion for people that are experiencing mental health difficulties and distress. And this is some of the ways that i um i don't like the grammar there i feel like i'm gonna edit that um but i'm not gonna edit it out because i'm not i'm not super perfectionistic so these are some of the ways that i use to just do a bit of weeding you know um just to gently cogitate assess think what's going on you've been a bit crankier than usual lately, Marianne, what do you think that might be about? And I think it's about that gentle curiosity that I would apply with clients as well. Why don't we try and do that for a bit?
节目。但我只是想加上那个免责声明，这样你就知道我根本不是在表现得傲慢。绝对不是，我对正在经历心理健康困难和痛苦的人们充满了同情。这些是我使用的一些方法，嗯，我不喜欢那里的语法，我觉得我要编辑一下，但我不会把它剪掉，因为我不是超级完美主义者。所以这些是我用来做一点除草工作的方法，你知道，嗯，只是轻轻地思考、评估、想一想发生了什么。你最近比平时更暴躁了，Marianne，你觉得这可能是什么原因？我认为这是一种我也会对客户应用的温和的好奇心。我们为什么不试着做一会儿呢？
And we'll just see whether that helps. And so that's what I would expect from myself. And that's what I would suggest can be useful when you're also working in mental health services and trying to look after yourself as well. So, yeah, let's let's crack on. And yeah, I just wanted to add that because it felt really important. So the second time I'm going to talk to you about is something more recent actually. So it was in the run-up to the summer holidays 2022 and I just had started to recognise that I was a bit grumpier than I ought to be, you know. So my baseline is usually pretty cheery, you know, I'm usually pretty easygoing, I usually smile quite often and, you know, can find the humour in most situations I just was like a bit irritable. And I was like, well, am I being irritable? Or is everyone around me actually really annoying? You know, how do you discern that? Is it me that's the problem? Or are they all really annoying? You know, I've got two kids and a husband. Is it just them?
我们来看看这是否有帮助。这就是我会对自己期望的。这也是我建议当你也在心理健康服务部门工作并试图照顾好自己时可以有用的方法。所以，是的，让我们继续。是的，我只是想补充这一点，因为它感觉非常重要。所以我要和你谈的第二个时刻实际上是最近发生的。那是在2022年暑假前夕，我刚开始意识到我比我应该表现得更暴躁一些，你知道。所以我的基准通常是相当开朗的，你知道，我通常相当随和，我通常经常微笑，并且，你知道，能在大多数情况下找到幽默感。我只是觉得有点易怒。我当时想，嗯，是我在易怒吗？还是我周围的每个人实际上真的很烦人？你知道，你怎么辨别呢？是我有问题吗？还是他们都很烦人？你知道，我有两个孩子和一个丈夫。只是他们吗？
Am I the problem? And I was like, I don't know. I'm not sure it's me. I don't know. But I thought, well, let's have a look at your life, Marianne. let's think about what might be going on to see if this could be you actually um so i did a little bit of a dissection really and it might be helpful at this stage to have a look at the maslow's hierarchy of needs so at the bottom of that pyramid i often do this with clients not about myself obviously um but with them we look at the physiological needs, which is air, water, food, shelter, sleep, clothing, reproduction. Then the next one up, we've got safety needs, which is personal security, employment, resources, health and property, love and belonging, friendship, intimacy, family, sense of connection. Next one up is esteem, respect, self-esteem, status, recognition, strength and freedom. And then right at the top, we've got self-actualization,
我是问题所在吗？我当时想，我不知道。我不确定是我。我不知道。但我心想，好吧，让我们看看你的生活，Marianne。让我们想想可能发生了什么，看看这是否真的是你。嗯，所以我做了一点剖析，在这个阶段看看马斯洛的需求层次理论可能会有帮助。在那个金字塔的底部，我经常和客户这样做，当然不是关于我自己，而是和他们一起，我们看看生理需求，即空气、水、食物、住所、睡眠、衣物、生殖。再往上一层，我们有安全需求，即人身安全、就业、资源、健康和财产。爱与归属感，友谊、亲密关系、家庭、联系感。再往上一层是尊重，尊重、自尊、地位、认可、力量和自由。然后在最顶端，我们有自我实现，
the desire to become the most that one can be. And so I was thinking, well, where am I doing really well at the moment? And I'm going to cite that one of the problems was Love Island, people. Ordinarily, my natural bedtime would be about 9.15. But when Love Island's on, it doesn't finish till 10pm. And I can't be catching up on TV every day because I'm very busy. And so I was watching it live with my husband. We're both Love Island fans um big news just in is that Laura Whitmore is not doing it next year who's going to present will it be Ekin
成为自己所能成为的一切的愿望。所以我当时在想，嗯，我目前在哪些方面做得很好？我要指出其中一个问题是《Love Island》（恋爱岛），各位。通常，我自然的就寝时间大约是9点15分。但当《Love Island》播出时，它要到晚上10点才结束。我不能每天都补看电视，因为我很忙。所以我当时和我的丈夫一起看直播。我们都是《Love Island》的粉丝，嗯，刚刚得到的大新闻是Laura Whitmore明年不做了，谁会主持呢？会是Ekin
Sue I heard yesterday I think that might be quite good I might be on board with that um but yeah my sleep suffers I get less of it um so to speak, during Love Island and not for the reasons you think, just because it's later. So it pushes back my bedtime routine by an hour, really, you know, almost an hour. And, you know, also in the UK since July, it's been unbearably hot. And in my 20s, and when I was a teenager, I loved hot weather. I was a real sun bunny. I adored it. But now that I am older than mid-20s, I just don't like it it is not for me I am not here for that um anything over 24 and I am like grumpy I like to be a bit chilly in bed and to be all snuggled up and have a duvet I can't wait I can't wait to need a duvet again I cannot wait um I literally I'm kind of hallucinating about how wonderful that's going to be.
Sue吗？我昨天听说的，我想那可能很不错，我可能会支持这一点。嗯，但是的，我的睡眠受到了影响，我睡得少了，可以说，在《Love Island》期间，不是因为你想的那样，只是因为它太晚了。所以它确实把我的睡前习惯推迟了一个小时，真的，几乎一个小时。而且，你知道，在英国自七月以来，天气热得让人难以忍受。在我20多岁和十几岁的时候，我喜欢炎热的天气。我真的是个“太阳兔”。我非常喜欢它。但现在我超过25岁了，我只是不喜欢它，它不适合我，我不是为了那个而来的。嗯，任何超过24度的天气，我就像个暴躁的人。我喜欢在床上凉快一点，蜷缩起来，盖上被子。我等不及了，我等不及再次需要被子了，我等不及了。嗯，我简直是在幻想着那会有多美妙。
And then in the next breath, I'm like, but then we might need heating and the heating is going to be expensive. So, yeah, I'm just looking forward to autumn when we don't need heating. trousers and blankets and pillows and you know that aren't covered in sweat and um you know duvets that are wonderful so I blooming can't wait um so yeah my sleep was being impacted on by that um so yeah I decided to to take that on board once love island was finished let's not go wild i'm not quitting mid-series um but i um decided to get my sleep hygiene back on board so i'm never really a caffeine drinker anyway i have the occasional um cup of green tea i don't eat much chocolate um but yeah i decided to see if I could start going to bed slightly earlier again. And I have done that.
然后下一秒，我就想，但那时我们可能需要暖气，暖气会很贵。所以，是的，我只是期待秋天，那时我们不需要暖气。长裤、毯子和枕头，你知道，没有被汗水浸透，嗯，你知道，美妙的被子。所以我简直等不及了。所以，是的，我的睡眠受到了影响。所以，是的，我决定一旦《Love Island》结束就把它纳入考虑。我们别太疯狂了，我不会在剧集播到一半时放弃的。但我决定让我的睡眠卫生恢复正常。所以我从来都不是一个喝咖啡的人，我偶尔喝一杯绿茶，我不怎么吃巧克力。但是的，我决定看看我是否能再次开始稍微早一点上床睡觉。我已经做到了。
And I looked at my food. So if you've been following me on Instagram, Dr. Marianne Trent, where all the good stuff happens on Insta. I decided to start trying to eat a bit better. So I decided to start trying to eat a bit more fruit and veg. And a couple of years ago, I was doing a 10 a day to eating 80 grams of 10 different fruit and veg for a whole year. I did it for a whole year. And at that point, I thought, I'm never going to change back. Well, this is just going to be me forever now. Like this is just going to be, this is going to be where it's at. You know, I can't see me ever changing, ever having this be any different. But then of course, like anything, things do change. So once I've done the year,
我看了看我的饮食。所以如果你一直在关注我的Instagram，Dr. Marianne Trent，所有好东西都在Insta上发生。我决定开始尝试吃得更好一点。所以我决定开始尝试多吃点水果和蔬菜。几年前，我曾做过“每天10份”，即一整年每天吃10种不同的水果和蔬菜，每种80克。我坚持了一整年。在那一点上，我想，我永远不会变回去了。好吧，这以后将永远是我。就像这就是它的所在。你知道，我看不出我会有什么改变，会有什么不同。但当然，像任何事情一样，事情确实会改变。所以一旦我做了一年，
things slipped. And before you know it, I was back down to probably eating a few portions a day but I just thought you know what I'm going to look at what changes I can make right now to really give myself the best chance of meeting my nutritional needs to support my optimal functioning which is what this is about and so I started taking vitamins every day again and because I am I was gonna say an older lady I'm not an older lady but I'm 41 so I've got to be thinking about our bone density started taking some calcium and vitamin D as well alongside that and some fish oils but also started I decided to buy a slow juicer um and if you'd like some more information about my slow juicer you can find that um in the show notes we'll pop that in there for you um but yeah slow juicer and I started doing some juicing and I've been
事情就滑坡了。不知不觉中，我又回到了每天只吃几份的状态。但我只是想，你知道吗，我要看看我现在能做出什么改变，真正给自己最好的机会来满足我的营养需求，以支持我的最佳功能，这就是重点。所以我开始每天再次服用维生素。因为我，我本来想说是一个年长的女士，我不是一个年长的女士，但我41岁了，所以我必须考虑我们的骨密度，开始服用一些钙和维生素D，以及一些鱼油。但也开始，我决定买一个慢速榨汁机。如果你想要一些关于我的慢速榨汁机的更多信息，你可以在节目说明中找到，我们会把它放在那里给你。嗯，但是的，慢速榨汁机，我开始做一些果汁，我一直
really really enjoying that um so I've been adding to my stories some other bits and pieces that I've been eating and drinking um but really enjoying it and um yeah I'm not going to go all renegade and say I'm going to do it every day for the rest of my life like I did with the 10 a day um but I certainly am enjoying that and so I'm going to continue that um so that's probably it for the bottom section um you know I am not employed I am self-employed but I was feeling safe um you know I was feeling healthy so I'm in good health um but I decided I would start running again so I'm doing strength training but over the summer I'm only doing once a week not twice because I got I've got kids, man, I've got two of them. And so to be around for them a bit more often,
非常非常喜欢它。所以我一直在我的故事中添加我正在吃和喝的其他一些零碎东西。但真的非常喜欢它。嗯，是的，我不会变得那么叛逆，说我会像做“每天10份”那样每天都做，直到我生命的尽头。但我确实很喜欢它，所以我打算继续下去。所以这大概就是底部区域的内容了。你知道，我没有被雇佣，我是自雇人士，但我感到安全。你知道，我感到健康，所以我身体健康。但我决定再次开始跑步。所以我正在做力量训练，但整个夏天我每周只做一次，而不是两次，因为我有孩子，伙计，我有两个。所以为了更多地陪伴他们，
I was doing strength training in the middle of the week, whereas I'd usually do it twice a week. And I decided, well, I can start running again. So I can start running before I start work, or if I'm not working, can do it at the weekends before I get showered and things so I started running again and I'm not a marathon runner I'm not very good at it if I'm honest um it's not really about that for me it's not about the speed it's not about the distance I only run for about 15 minutes it's about moving my body and knowing that my mental health responds really well to having been run like a dog like getting out getting some fresh air having that time to think oh look there's blackberries going on that bush um or there's a dog poop that missed that avoid avoid avoid um or just saying hi to
我会在周中做力量训练，而我通常会每周做两次。所以我决定，好吧，我可以再次开始跑步。所以我可以在开始工作前跑步，或者如果我不工作，可以在周末洗澡前做。所以我再次开始跑步了。我不是马拉松运动员，说实话我不太擅长。嗯，这对我来说并不是关于那个，不是关于速度，不是关于距离。我只跑大约15分钟。这是关于活动我的身体，并知道我的心理健康对像狗一样奔跑、出去呼吸新鲜空气、有时间思考“哦看，那个灌木丛上有黑莓”或者“有一坨狗屎没避开，避开避开避开”或者只是向
people in the street you know and you know catching you know flowers coming out for the first time and watching the way the breeze moves the trees and noticing how parched all of the grasses and stuff at the moment so getting out and about um is really useful for me i respond well to that but depending on your own unique physiology and your physical health you may not be able to do that but still moving your body is really useful for our mental health I almost said yental health then mental health so yeah could you look to do that as well love and belonging so yeah I felt I made my husband in a pretty good place we've been together almost 13 years and married almost 10 um so it's not a first flash of love and we have got two children but yeah I felt like we were good enough um um where we're at um we
街上的人打招呼，你知道，捕捉第一次开出的花朵，观察微风吹动树木的方式，注意到此时所有的草地是多么干枯，这些事情反应非常好。所以出去走走对我来说真的很有用。我对此反应良好，但根据你独特的生理机能和身体健康状况，你可能无法做到这一点。但仍然，活动你的身体对我们的心理健康非常有用。（我刚才差点说成“yental health”，是“mental health”）。所以，是的，你也可以考虑这样做。爱与归属感，是的，我觉得我和我丈夫处于一个相当不错的位置。我们在一起快13年了，结婚快10年了。所以这不是初恋的冲动，我们有两个孩子。但是的，我觉得我们足够好了，嗯，在我们所处的位置。我们
like each other we still make each other laugh um we like spending time together we do tend to protect um at least an hour um to together each evening when we're both in we're usually both in um to spend time together um before we had kids we'd do like cool stuff like play rummy um have a glass of wine maybe sometimes um and play downfall you won't beat me at downfall. Don't think you can because you won't. Very rarely does anyone beat me at downfall. But, yeah, we'd spend time doing stuff other than watching TV,
喜欢彼此，我们仍然让对方发笑。我们喜欢在一起度过时光。我们确实倾向于保护，嗯，每天晚上我们都在家时，至少有一个小时在一起。我们通常都在家，在孩子们上床睡觉前在一起度过时光。在我们有孩子之前，我们会做一些很酷的事情，比如玩拉米纸牌，喝杯红酒，有时，玩Downfall（一种游戏）。你赢不了我的Downfall。别以为你能，因为你赢不了。很少有人能在Downfall中打败我。但是，是的，我们会花时间做除了看电视以外的事情。
but largely these days we do watch TV. But we spend time together usually on a Saturday and we'll have an earlier tea together, just me and him, once the kids are in bed. And then we spend time together then as well. So, yeah, I felt like that was good. Saturday and we'll have an earlier tea together just me and him once the kids are in bed and then we spend time together then as well so we yeah I felt like that was good but I recognize that even though I've got loads of friends that most of them are not on my immediate doorstep but I'm very very fortunate that one of my one of my um has got a best friend and it just so turns out
但这些天我们大部分时间确实在看电视。但我们通常在周六在一起度过，我们会早点一起喝茶，就我和他，一旦孩子们上床睡觉。然后我们也会在那之后在一起度过时光。所以，是的，我觉得那很好。周六，我们会早点一起喝茶，就我和他，一旦孩子们上床睡觉，然后我们也会在那之后在一起度过时光。所以我们，是的，我觉得那很好。但我意识到，即使我有许多朋友，但他们大多数都不在我的家门口。但我非常非常幸运，我的其中一个，嗯，有一个最好的朋友，结果
that me and his mum get on really really well and so I decided that um yeah we'll start spending some more time together as well it doesn't just need to be when the kids are um you know together and so we've been planning more time together we're off out together um for dinner for the first time this um this coming friday actually um as i record this um and yeah we just i went around to see her the other day on her birthday we just you know laughed our heads off like it's just really nice um to be able to have a friend right on my doorstep so yeah i've got friends i trained with that are living locally to me um but when I say locally to me, it's still about half an hour away and half an hour away may as well be, you know, three hours
我和他的妈妈相处得非常好。所以我决定，嗯，是的，我们将开始更多地在一起度过时光。这不需要仅仅是在孩子们在一起的时候。所以我们一直在计划更多的时间在一起。我们正要一起出去，嗯，为了晚餐，这是第一次，嗯，这个即将到来的周五，实际上，在我录制这个的时候。是的，我们只是，我前几天在她生日那天去看她，我们只是，你知道，笑得前仰后合。这真的很好，能够有一个就在我门口的朋友。所以，是的，我有和我一起训练的朋友住在离我很近的地方。但当我说是离我很近时，它仍然大约有半小时的路程。半小时的路程可能就像，你知道，三个小时
away because I still wasn't seeing them. But I did make a trip to go and see two of my friends who live about half an hour away and really, really enjoyed connecting with them and yeah right at the start of the summer I went away and connected with three of my undergrad friends and we went and stayed away in a beautiful little cottage with a hot tub it was really nice so just really looking at where I could thicken the narrative around my friendships to make sure that I was checking off that area of the Maslow's hierarchy and yeah continuing to plan in activities that are enjoyable and things to look forward to so yeah that's the love and belonging section and the sense of connection and all of that and then really enjoyed our little family holiday as well
那么远，因为我仍然没有见到他们。但我确实去看了我的两个住在半小时路程之外的朋友，真的，真的非常享受与他们的联系。是的，在夏天刚开始的时候，我出去和我的三个本科朋友联系了，我们去住在一个带热水浴缸的美丽小木屋里，这真的很好。所以只是真正地审视我可以在哪里加深我友谊的叙事，以确保我正在勾选马斯洛需求层次理论的那个领域。是的，继续计划令人愉快的活动和值得期待的事情。所以，是的，这就是爱与归属感部分，以及联系感等等。然后也非常享受我们的小家庭假期，
when we went down to East Wittering spending time together and also having a bit more sleep as well, which topped up those needs. And yeah, just a more relaxed pace of life. So you will know that I like to get things done. You know, there's always busy plates spinning in my life, be they personal or professional or both. It's just nice to take my foot off the gas for a bit and just lean into being on holiday self-esteem I feel like I respect myself feeling all right yeah feeling okay with what I'm doing and self-actualization you know I absolutely even when I was feeling a bit wobbly and a bit moany and you know I still wanted to do well it wasn't like I was feeling a bit wobbly and a bit moany and um you know I still wanted to do well it wasn't like I was saying I can't do that I mustn't do that I just was a bit concerned
当我们去East Wittering时，在一起度过时光，也多睡了一会儿，这补充了那些需求。是的，只是更放松的生活节奏。所以你会知道我喜欢把事情做好。你知道，我的生活中总是有忙碌的盘子在旋转，无论是个人还是职业，或者两者兼有。稍微松开油门，沉浸在度假中真是太好了。自尊，我觉得我尊重自己，感觉还行，是的，对自己正在做的事情感觉还可以。自我实现，你知道，我绝对，即使当我感觉有点摇摆不定、有点抱怨时，你知道，我仍然想做得好。并不是说我感觉有点摇摆不定、有点抱怨，嗯，你知道，我仍然想做得好。并不是说我在说“我做不到，我不能做那个”。我只是有点担心
about my general levels irritability um and I can report I'm recording this at the end of August I'm feeling really good again um so maybe maybe was me, or maybe the children not being at school and not having to hustle them out the door is meaning they're less annoying. They are causing me to be less irritated. You know, we are spending time together. And so they've got my attention. I'm always quite careful that at the end of every day at bedtime that we have a little review of the day and um you know we'll say what's our favorite part of the day what's our least favorite part of the day my eldest tries to chuck in what is my funniest part of the day and i'm like baby boy life's not that funny when you're 41. Like, it's very rare that I'll laugh my head off uncontrollably.
关于我普遍的易怒水平。我可以报告，我是在八月底录制这个的，我感觉又非常好。所以也许，也许是我，或者也许是孩子们不在学校，不需要催促他们出门，意味着他们不那么烦人了。他们导致我没那么易怒。你知道，我们在一起度过时光。所以他们得到了我的关注。我总是很小心，在每天睡觉前，我们都会对这一天进行一个小回顾，嗯，你知道，我们会说我们这一天最喜欢的部分是什么，最不喜欢的部分是什么。我的大儿子试图加入“我这一天最有趣的部分是什么”，我说：“宝贝，当你41岁时，生活没那么有趣。”就像，我很难会无法控制地大笑。
You know, I wish that happened more often. I do find myself quite amusing. But yeah, life's not as, you know, spontaneously gleeful as it is when you're nine or when you when you're six so often i'll say no we're not doing we're not do not do it not doing the funny one today um so we do the best part which is probably a bit miserable you're like marianne that's so grumpy um so yeah maybe i just need to find more opportunities to laugh in every given day um but the kids are always a bit disappointed if my favorite part of the day is not with them it's something different but i think that is role
你知道，我希望这种情况发生得更多。我确实觉得我自己很有趣。但是的，生活不像你九岁或六岁时那样自发地快乐。所以通常我会说：“不，我们不做，我们不做，今天不做那个有趣的。”所以我们做最好的部分，这可能有点悲惨。你会说：“Marianne，那太暴躁了。”所以，是的，也许我只需要在每一天找到更多大笑的机会。但如果我最喜欢的一天不是和他们在一起，而是其他事情，孩子们总是有点失望。但我认为那是角色
modeling appropriate that they are not the kings of this world and that there can be joy found outside of being their mother um good job i don't rely on them solely for my joy they eat a lot of it eat my joy um which if you're not a parent yourself you might be like how could she speak about her children like that but um you know they're they're like pac-man you know they gobble up your free time they gobble up your money um you know they get me a drink oh no darling let's try again ask me again please can i have drink please and i was like well i suppose so what did your last slave die of um you know but if i let them make it themselves it'd be squash everywhere but so, I'm happy to be the drinks machine.
建模，适当的，他们不是这个世界的国王，在做他们的母亲之外还可以找到快乐。好工作，我不完全依赖他们来获得我的快乐。他们吃了很多，吃掉了我的快乐。如果你自己不是父母，你可能会想“她怎么能那样谈论她的孩子”。但，嗯，你知道，他们就像吃豆人（Pac-Man），你知道，他们吞噬了你的空闲时间，他们吞噬了你的钱。嗯，你知道，他们给我拿了一杯饮料，“哦不，亲爱的，让我们再试一次，再问我一次，请问我可以喝饮料吗？”我当时想，“好吧，我想可以。你的上一个奴隶是怎么死的？”你知道，但如果我让他们自己做，到处都会是果汁。所以，我很乐意成为饮料机。
But I want someone to speak to me politely. I don't want to be spoken to like a slave because I ain't nobody's slave. So, yeah, I'm sharing this level of vulnerability with you to invite you to reflect on your own Maslow's hierarchy, to invite you to reflect on whether you could be pathologizing yourself and what control you might be able to have to make changes in your life. So, you you know it's no surprise that people with the best mental health are generally getting good sleep they are connected to people they are feeling like they've got a sense of achievement that they're seeing people that they like regularly either in person or remotely they're feeling connected to something they feel like they are achieving they are eating good food
但我希望有人礼貌地和我说话。我不想被像奴隶一样对待，因为我不是任何人的奴隶。所以，是的，我正在与你分享这种脆弱程度，以邀请你反思你自己的马斯洛需求层次，邀请你反思你是否可能在对自己进行病理化，以及你可能有什么控制权来改变你的生活。所以，你知道，这并不奇怪，心理健康最好的人通常睡眠良好，他们与人有联系，他们感觉自己有成就感，他们定期见到他们喜欢的人，无论是亲自还是远程，他们感到与某事有联系，他们觉得自己在实现目标，他们在吃好的食物，
you know um and so anytime that I feel like I'm slipping away from that it's useful just to take a little bit of a look um and to make sure that where possible I can make tweaks and make changes to get myself yeah on a more even keel you know because I am 41 I did wonder whether I could be perimenopausal as well and um this isn't really something I'd considered much before um you know Davina has been talking a lot about that over the last couple of years and she's got a book coming out that I'm quite looking forward to reading as well um it looks pretty as well I saw her with a copy of it on her Instagram recently um you know so is that around for me I don't know I think my mum went through the menopause she'll be mortified been telling you this a bit later than 41 I think she's probably
你知道，嗯，所以任何时候我觉得我正在偏离这一点，稍微看一看是有用的，并确保在可能的情况下，我可以做出调整和改变，让自己，是的，处于一个更平稳的状态。你知道，因为我41岁了，我确实想过我是否也可能处于围绝经期。嗯，这并不是我以前考虑过很多的事情。你知道，Davina在过去几年里一直在谈论这个，她有一本书要出版，我也很期待阅读。它看起来也很漂亮，我最近在她的Instagram上看到她拿着一本。你知道，所以这对我来说存在吗？我不知道。我想我妈妈经历了更年期，如果我告诉你们这个，她会感到羞愧，比41岁晚一点，我想她可能……
late 40s um so yeah I don't think that's the case you know am I just a bit grumpy is that but I feel I don't know I feel energized when it comes to my work you know I'm not annoyed with you guys no um and so is it just that my kids were going through a bit of a grumpy demanding phase were they worn out was I worn out from the end of the school year have we all responded really nicely to this protracted family time and that said um i have been able to record this podcast this afternoon um well i was going to record it anyway but instead of ignoring my children my mother-in-law texted me and said oh do they want to come over to this afternoon i said yes yes they do i'm bringing them now see you soon um so yeah i've been able to record um two podcast episodes with them not in the house hooray um i wonder whether i'll be able
快五十岁了，嗯，所以我认为情况并非如此。你知道，我只是有点脾气暴躁吗？但我感觉，我不知道，我在工作时感到精力充沛，你知道，我并没有对你们感到恼火。嗯，所以是不是因为我的孩子们正处于一个有点暴躁、要求苛刻的阶段？他们累了吗？我是不是因为学年结束而精疲力竭了？我们是否都对这段漫长的家庭时光做出了很好的回应？话虽如此，嗯，我今天下午能够录制这期播客，嗯，我本来就要录制的，但与其忽视我的孩子们，我婆婆给我发短信说，哦，他们今天下午想过来吗？我说，是的，是的，他们想，我现在就带他们过去，一会儿见。嗯，所以是的，我能够录制两期播客，而他们不在家里，万岁。嗯，我不知道我是否能够
to get any editing done before they call they get home probably not probably not um but yes um i can't remember why i told you that uh no can't remember but could you use these techniques to look at helping you be your optimal self you know what tweaks could you make um let me know won't you um come along and discuss it with me on the Aspiring Psychologist community, in the Aspiring Psychologist community Facebook group. I'd love to know what you think of this episode, anything that it's evoked or provoked for you. Let's continue this conversation. And yeah, thank you for being kind with me as i
在他们回家之前完成任何剪辑工作，可能不会，可能不会。但是是的，嗯，我不记得我为什么要告诉你那个了，嗯，不，记不起来了，但你能利用这些技巧来帮助你成为最佳状态的自己吗？你知道你可以做出哪些调整？让我知道，好吗？来和我一起在“有抱负的心理学家”社区，在“有抱负的心理学家”Facebook群组中讨论它。我很想知道你对这一集的看法，它为你唤起或激发了什么。让我们继续这个对话。是的，谢谢你对我保持友善，因为我
bear my soul um and yeah looking forward to catching up with you for what will be episode 41 very soon you said 40 how cool is that have you listened to all 40 so far are you like you know a regular let me know um come and connect on socials i love celebrating with you i'm dr marianne trent most places but you can check out my link tree um all the details in the show notes um all right take care be kind to yourselves thanks for being part of my world bye if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast.
敞开心扉，嗯，是的，期待很快与你见面，这将是第41集。你说40集，这太酷了，你到目前为止听过全部40集了吗？你是一个常客吗？让我知道，来社交媒体上联系我，我喜欢和你一起庆祝。我在大多数地方都是玛丽安·特伦特博士，但你可以查看我的Linktree，所有详细信息都在节目说明中。好的，保重，善待自己，感谢你成为我世界的一部分，再见。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这就是“有抱负的心理学家”播客。
With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay.
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。